this episode 46 of congratulations the
podcast is brought to you by movement
look we get it holiday shopping can be
tough but thanks to movement all that
gift-giving anxiety can disappear with
the press of a button these watches make
the perfect purchase for just about
everyone in your life guy or girl and
remember they start at only $95 and get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Congrats blue apron when you cook with
blue apron you're not just having
burgers for dinner you're making short
rib burgers with a hoppy cheddar sauce
on a pretzel bun you're preparing seared
steaks and thyme pan sauce with mashed
potatoes green beans and crispy shallots
all in under 45 minutes and without a
trip to the grocery store blue apron is
treating my listeners to their first
three meals a $30 value with your first
order if if you go visit blue apron com
/ Congrats so check out this week's menu
and get your $30 off with free shipping
at blue apron calm / Congrats blue apron
a better way to cook guys don't forget
about the cash out it seems the babies
are switching to the cash app as it's
the number one finance app in the App
Store they've introduced the cash card a
new black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app allowing you to use
the cash that you keep in the app
anywhere you want plus it's the best way
to pay people back download the free
cash app for iOS or Android now
[Music]
what's up guys it's episode 46 cannulate
I'm heading out in every episode like I
said I would buy Tuesday for 45 times
the 46th time I got a job I had to fly
up to Vancouver or was I don't like to
call it Kobe and I had to flap there and
I had to shoot an episode of the good
doctor and I had to stack that cheddar a
little bit let's be honest I had to
stack the cheddar
I had to flap north pick up some [ __ ]
Gouda and come back down now I'm gonna
be in the good doctor I'm gonna be in a
few episodes of it you know they didn't
want that II - just a little [ __ ]
hang around for one episode they wanted
the [ __ ] Adam - a few more episodes
what am I gonna do am I gonna do not do
it gotta do it they want to help me
[ __ ] you know what I mean they want
they do they do they need me to get a
[ __ ] do they need me to rent out a
self-storage garage I'll do it
I'll put stacks of cheddar and a
self-storage garage a garage I'll do you
know I'll do it you know one time I we
were driving by a I was on my way back
from saying Sacramento with my buddy
and we were driving by a self-storage
place and I chant and I looked at it and
I pointed and I said let us out let us
out like like you know you store
yourself in there and the guy I was with
left all so hard and he continued it
would tell me years later this is the
funniest thing I ever said he was crying
so hard he was laughing and now every
time I Drive by self-storage place I say
let so what no public storage is what it
was public stores right public storage
yeah those orange ones well one fire
immediately [ __ ] promote himself to
one hire you just [ __ ] correct me even
though don't correct me in public
seriously helped even though don't
correct me while I'm [ __ ] well
hundreds of thousands of people are
gonna hear this [ __ ] one hire one
promote so
guys I have an announcement before we
get [ __ ] rip-roarin and going all of
the merch is restocked it's because of
the stock it's all restocked go get your
freak on ch hoodies cuz it's cold out
and you want people to know it's
Afrikaans even though you're near your
fireplace you want people to know you
don't stand with kouddous let's go get
the note Cooter's of the Kikuta shirts
while you're sitting down with your
family this holiday season so why don't
you go get a true baby shirt or Chris
Chris D'Elia [ __ ] rock shirt middle
tea or [ __ ] tired Eagle shits why
don't you go get him [ __ ] stock them
all up baby's skill get him now I wasn't
man Cooper I was in San Jose I was in I
was in San Jose I did my due to by the
way I sound even more like the narcos
guy with this with my cold I had a cold
and it was like one of those colds where
I was like I'm not gonna get sick for
like nine days and then the tenth and
eleventh day I was like
um but uh yeah so bunch of stuff
happened I was like oh dude is gonna be
good because oh by the way guys if I say
on on social media I'm gonna be here's
what a true baby does you checked my
social media if something's not
happening on Monday if you're not
getting a podcast on Monday or Tuesday
check the social media before you
[ __ ] comment
hey where's the podcast put up the
[ __ ] podcast cause here's the thing
dude my my [ __ ] when it comes to
blocking I got a trigger finger dude I
got an itchy trigger finger I don't I
don't practice [ __ ] trigger what do
they call it trigger safety what do they
call it what the [ __ ] gun they put
the you put your finger on the gun you
don't put it on the trigger I don't
practice that dude with my block that's
what I do I'm if you [ __ ] comment
negative [ __ ] on my Instagram I'm a
Twitter or whatever the [ __ ] I am it on
YouTube comments babies dude if you
comment that I'm welcoming you to my
block party here's a here's a burger
here's a hotdog
there's relish down there and [ __ ]
plastic forks you're welcomed to my
block party and guess what happens at
the block party you never get uninvited
I don't unblock people it's simply and
I'm gonna say it like this do it and
this is the most disrespectful way to
say it it's simply done now if you get
blocked getting unblocked done app it's
it you made your bed you Lane it if you
made your bed consider yourself
horizontal you're not being [ __ ]
perpendicular with the ground you being
parallel to the ground you made your bed
stay horizontal
all right welcome to my block party the
[ __ ] sauerkraut is down at the other
end we got Third Eye Blind playing here
baby
go out in the park enjoy your pork you
[ __ ] say shitty things you made your
bed you stain horizontal that's it no if
ands buts Roy Moore looked stupid as
[ __ ] in his horse didn't he hey Roy
Moore you look too dumb as [ __ ] riding
away all [ __ ] zigzaggy on your horse
dude if you can't [ __ ] ride a horse
in a straight line don't ride a horse
when people are taking pictures of you
when people are taking video I have a
video of you don't ride a horse if you
can't go in a straight line now what the
narcos didn't know was dude don't ride a
horse all zigzaggy all straight legged
and [ __ ] has anybody ever ridden a horse
not with a brown suede jacket on by the
way it's the most horsey [ __ ] driving
jacket of all time
Oh Manny went left he went right it went
lefty run right the horse is like it's
going on dude dude by the way I posted
up the [ __ ] video of Roy Moore's
spokesperson who [ __ ] when did you
see was it Tapper what's the guy's name
Jake Tapper who was when he was the
saying when Jake Tapper was like when
the gut what was the spokespersons name
I don't even know seeping find that out
or otherwise one fire but he was like he
was like when you after when you have to
be a senator you have to swear on the
Bible and if you're Muslim you can't
swear on the Bible and then Jake Tapper
was like well you actually don't you
could swear on anything you can swear on
a [ __ ] Harry Potter book and he was
like I did it and Jake Tapper was like
boom I'm sure he did Ted
rocket is his name and the only thing I
have to say about that is of course his
name is Ted Crockett I mean could that
guy's name be anything but Ted Crockett
he was the dude and he was like well I'm
sure you did pick the Bible because you
picked that he was like but you don't
have to pick the Bible and the
spokesperson was like uh Donald Trump
did it he was like that's cuz he chose
it and he was just mouth open like a
crocodile
dude are you waiting for a deer No then
speak or close you mouth dude Ted
Crockett was [ __ ] Stan sitting there
looking like a crocodile for way too
long just blinking blinking he was a if
he was a president he would be a
blinking and [ __ ] tapper was trying
to wait he was like um you want to
answer and he was just like uh and he
was blinking and it was so funny and
here's the deal man
35 [ __ ] what was it like over 30
people accused Roy Moore of sexual
harassment if 35 people are accusing you
I don't give a [ __ ] if you rode
Republican Democrat dude 35 people look
cute 80 people accused Bill Cosby
fuck'em okay Harvey Weinstein [ __ ] them
all right I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are so I posted it on it on Instagram I
was like when you're a pedophile when
you when you think of pedophile is gonna
be senator and he's not and people are
like you [ __ ] liberal agenda I don't
have an agenda I don't have a [ __ ]
agenda dude I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're liberal or dude you know how many
of these liberals or corny ass whiny
[ __ ] babies I don't support them
either I don't give a [ __ ] don't be a
whiny baby and don't be racist period
don't be a whiny baby and don't be
[ __ ] racist and don't [ __ ] kids play
symp it's plain and simple up a
restaurant that's called
splain and simp and you come in you
order some [ __ ] grits
you order some burgers you order some
vegan [ __ ] we've got a lot of stuff okay
whatever you order there's this cafe in
[ __ ] la called Cafe Gratitude and
every time you go to Cafe Gratitude
they [ __ ] tell you something to think
about they're like our question of the
day is and I go like this in my head I
go zip it
our question of the day is what makes
you proud zip it what makes me proud is
apricot and someone asked me a question
before you mate don't ask what your
question of the day is what makes you
humble by oh really
go ask yourself that in the kitchen all
right my [ __ ] restaurant is plain and
simple
and then they go like this hey welcome
to sur plane to sim our [ __ ]
statement of the days don't [ __ ] kids
say yeah we got no agenda and then they
go and they bring your [ __ ] grits mmm
Crockett [ __ ] eats so much grits you
know while he's blinking with the
crocodile mouth uh Trump did it all cool
man
see ya oh dude Hey Dude check out all
the points going here's something for
the video pod that's how the [ __ ]
point went didn't go in your brain hmm
but like tapper tried not to [ __ ]
slam him tap was like hey bud help me
out here you're on TV
he literally like was like you don't
have to [ __ ] swim Bible did you know
that and tap her [ __ ] blinked so hard
I swear I heard
like a cartoon you cartoon croc then zip
it stop blinking like a cartoon but dude
that was the best man so posted on the
Instagram and everyone's like you're
[ __ ] liberal agenda hey dude joke and
somebody was like stick to comedy
it's a [ __ ] meme for [ __ ] sake it's
a meme it's a meme you know how they
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] online it's a wife
it's a meme there come on man shut hey
dude anybody who says that anybody who
says stick to comedy to a comedian
especially on a joke shut the [ __ ] up
okay hey dude I got a [ __ ] FedEx
package for you open it up you know what
it says shut the [ __ ] up I mean come on
do it
also you can't say shut the [ __ ] up when
you got 36 followers nobody wants to
hear
they were like nobody wants to hear what
you say about politics really how to
[ __ ] the Bill Maher get a goddamn
correct
I got quest for you how the [ __ ] did
Dennis Miller get a goddamn career shut
the [ __ ] up
eat my shorts dude let me put salad
dressing on my shorts eat it up then
then I swear to God one day my podcast
is just literally gonna be contractions
dude you don't get to say keep your
opinions to yourself on Twitter
that's what Twitter's for expressing
opinions for people to people who don't
give a [ __ ]
follow me or don't also by I'll tweet
whatever the [ __ ] I want I don't give a
[ __ ]
follow me or don't follow me I could
[ __ ] rub my nuts all day long on
Twitter I don't give a [ __ ] you can
literally show your dick on Twitter
there's girls out there oiling up their
butts and getting [ __ ] by mechanical
dildos on the other end of a robot on
that's just going man yeah through how
violent are those things you ever seen
that [ __ ] you ever see when they [ __ ]
go doggy style and the [ __ ] thing is
like it's so [ __ ] weirdly like the
arm will just [ __ ] keep pumping dude
that's violent as [ __ ] and it's all
oiled up and like who else is in the
room it's always some guy with like
[ __ ] rubber gloves the [ __ ] are you
doing hey see childhood like it's get
raised by a [ __ ] cyborg that molested
you
what are those [ __ ] ramen asks did
it's so violent and then when they turn
around they go on their back it's even
worse because you you're literally
looking you know how like when you're
[ __ ] and you're making love and the
shit's [ __ ] so nice and inspirational
and you're like look at me make eye
contact and you're drooling you got
nothing to look at dude you got nothing
to look at but a brown room that's
always what those [ __ ] mechanic what
are those things called dude and they
always have like a [ __ ] like it looks
like a churning mechanism on the side of
it
that's not going the way it makes it
weirder because the [ __ ] robot thing
is like pumping at a [ __ ] parallel to
the ground and the but the churning
thing is pumping upward because that's
how [ __ ] this mechanics works you
know I don't know dick but like it'll be
[ __ ] pumping upward and it's all
weird because it's pumping upward and
the [ __ ] thing is getting sideways so
it's like weirdly like you can get
[ __ ] while you're thinking like why
does that make mechanism going upward
but I'm getting [ __ ] parallel you know
like that's like dude the most sexy
thought you can have during sex has
nothing to do with sex you know what I'm
talking about that's what I was talking
about when you can hear garbage trucks
while you're [ __ ] a 430 Dan get a
danged a danged of dangler
that's where the [ __ ] squirt happens
man oh man you know you clicked on those
videos you ever been watching porn and
you're like let's start with some BJ
stuff and then all of a sudden it just
like you be like oh huh what are
Japanese people up to and they're just
like throwing up on each other hey throw
up on my [ __ ] like that like what
throwing up like on some [ __ ] poor
Japanese business man's face in the
forest and other Japanese guys are
watching you know with all with grey
suits on dude is nothing more Japanese
than wearing a gray suit and get a throw
it up on your face nothing dude nothing
more Japanese than having dude straight
up then having a gray suit on with your
tie loosened getting your face thrown up
on in the forest with no pants on and
your pubic hair is longer than your deck
nothing more Japanese than that bro and
having [ __ ] like like 20 year-old
Japanese women just like throwing up on
his face and other Japanese men watching
you shooting it with a real camera not
an iPhone but then also other guys
shooting it with an iPhone that was a
hell of a tangent huh
was I talking about Roy Moore hey dude
if you ride on a horse to your election
I'm not voting for you I don't give a
[ __ ] if you're Jesus Christ or Sammy
Davis jr. okay
[ __ ] ROI more you know most basic
name of all time to Roy Moore and Tom
Crockett Ted Crockett even whiter Ted
Roy Moore and Ted Crockett they either
say racist [ __ ] or they don't say [ __ ]
alright baby mm-hmm
here we go texture whether you're
looking for dependable political
reporting high quality storytelling or
the latest on culture and entertainment
magazines deliver it with all with high
quality writing and beautiful
photography and now you can get all your
magazines in one place with texture the
texture app gives you unlimited access
to over 200 premium magazines texture
has leading titles like time the
Atlantic The New Yorker Vanity Fair and
Wired and right now you can try texture
for free that's right I try it I put all
my magazines that I have in the texture
app on my iPad and it's really nice to
be able to jump from one magazine to the
other without having to you know jump
into a new app right a lot of these
magazines have their apps but that's
that's not the way to do it the way to
do it is with texture texture just
imagine having your favorite magazines
and their back issues anytime anywhere
to start your texture free trial go to
texture dot-com / Congrats
if you choose to continue podcast
listeners will get texture for just
$9.99 a month that's over 30% off
they're listed price there are also
great gift options available for the
holiday season go to texture comm /
congrats to start your free trial today
that's texture dot-com / Congrats
texture dot-com / Congrats movement
mm-hmm you've heard me talk about
movement and I'm sure you've got
yourself a watch now let's finish your
holiday shopping and get a movement
watch for someone on your list okay
movement watches starts at just $95 at a
department store you're looking at 400
to 500 bucks movement figured out by
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup providing
the best possible price at such great
price prices movement watches make
wonderful holiday gifts to over 1
million watches sold in over 160
countries didn't even know there were
that many countries I thought there were
7 my own watch is very cool when I wear
my movement watch I wear it out because
it's [ __ ] it's gold and it's sleek looks
like I'm a Jetson
I'm very futuristic people are like go
what is that and I'm like it's the
texture you got to try this stuff out
get 50% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Congrats it's got a really cool design
makes for a great fashion statement and
you know I'm in a fashion dude you see
my Instagram posts lately now is the
type time to step up your watch game go
to MVM t.com slash Congrats join the
movement
yeah dude those likes and how about the
sibian porn it's so mechanical you know
where they just sit on a [ __ ] roll
robot then it mmm no no anyway I forgot
my family listens to this podcast so
cool cool hey anyway pretty cool how now
you know I've watched robot porn shout
out to my guys at true crime garage they
they mentioned coming to my show in Ohio
they got a good podcast that is about
crime crime stories and and they're
great I like them they're good guys too
they're fun to chill with mmm they gave
us a shout-out on their podcast who I
love so it's nice babies helping babies
you know what I'm talking about
they're nice but they're not you know
what dude actually that's the worst way
to describe somebody is nice they're
cool and they're fun I can't say and if
somebody but if anyone ever were to
describe me as nice that was the
first thing it's nice to be described as
nice but that's the first thing someone
describes ya as pack your [ __ ] bags
guess what that dude is born a [ __ ]
sleep let me get him my pillow I'm gonna
taking that while I hang out with a nice
guy yeah he's nice
how is she can you describe her uh my
buddies are thinking about setting you
up with set me up with her oh she's nice
oh really cool is she an ambien
is she a [ __ ] long flight with no
turbulence that's nice I'd rather be
[ __ ] rude than nice at least it's
interesting I was at UM I was in San
Jose and he let me tell me actually
here's a glimpse into a life as a
[ __ ] d-list celebrity which I am so I
was going to I had some 20s on me and I
wanted to go change him into big Bill's
so they fit in my [ __ ] pocket okay I
think the Lord just did that to me
because I was bragging anyway I was
going to get larger bills uh and as I
was doing I was on a mission I was
walking to the [ __ ] concierge mm-hmm
by the way the name sounds too French
change it just to have it be like desk
guy uh I was gonna and I was going and I
was going this girls like oh hi can I
say hi to you as I was walking and I
stopped I was walking very fast I
stopped and I said oh hi how's it going
and then I real and then she says hi and
then I and then I went to go walk again
and then she's like okay that's it and I
said Wow I don't know and then I kept
walking right
finish my jaw my [ __ ] change into the
money got three hundred dollar bills now
still not braggin changed it to sounded
cool now it's knocks it was only three
went back to now I'm in the lam in the
lounge area this is later with my
openers this girl with her two friends
comes back up to me and she's like hey
just wanted to say we're big fans and I
was like are cool you know I really
appreciate that we were talking for a
little bit and then she was like you
were really you were really rude earlier
and I said what and she was like when
you said when you said hi and I was like
this is an interesting thing I said
because I was I want you to understand
some I was absolutely not rude to you in
the least and she was like yeah you were
and I said okay well what happened and
she said well you stop I asked you to
say I and you stop and you said hi and
then you just left and I was like all
right so now put yourself in the shoes
of a d-list celebrity like myself okay
someone asks you you don't know while
they're walking fast I might add saqqaq
to say I might add but hey can I say hi
to you and then you stop oh hi and then
they say hi and then there's a beat and
you don't know what to do
you made this situation awkward by
stopping somebody and saying can I say
hi to you which is fine I did that then
it was on you to talk hey it's still
your turn hi hi okay you go she didn't
she then I was like okay and she said oh
that's it huh hey girl
this is Earth and now I'm the rude guy
the [ __ ] was I supposed to do give her a
massage she
that's not right it's not right and I
stand for all the d-list celebrities
plus CB and a-list celebrities I'm sure
it happens too even way more but it's
like people think you're rude
I've had people be like you you were so
rude when you took a picture with me
I took the goddamn picture with you well
what am I supposed to do
stroke you off am I supposed to make you
a ham sandwich plus if you're a fan of
mine you know my [ __ ] attitude it's
all love baby it's all love but you go
and waste my time dude you gonna make me
feel awkward
I'm parachuting the [ __ ] out of this
plane dude lady was nice she was a sweet
she was her friends were sweethearts
they came up too we had a whole
conversation and they were sweet you
know I'm really not a rude person but
sometimes I come off that way because I
don't know what to do hmm can I say how
do you yeah sure Hey
oh cool hey-oh bring a combo bring a
conversation man otherwise what are we
doing here yeah but describing someone
is nice but it
just like mmm I don't know
San Jose babies came out it was fun man
had a good time perform at the San Jose
I'm for a really great staff management
they're really great and then mm-hmm
what else happened this week it's been
nine days since I've done a podcast man
carefully we've been doing this podcast
for about a year now
[Music]
yeah pretty wild actually how about
these [ __ ] Christmas songs you know
what I don't what I don't mind Christmas
songs I don't mind I don't [ __ ] mind
I got a buddy and he's like you know
Chris Paul he's always like oh they
started the [ __ ] Christmas songs
everyone everyone everyone every year
goes like this oh man they keep starting
to Christmas songs early and earlier
earlier and earlier hey dude you know
what no they don't they start them over
in [ __ ] November always everyone says
it every year if everyone said it if
that were true they'd be starting in
[ __ ] August they'd be [ __ ] have
yourself a merry little Christmas in
[ __ ] April eventually Oh every year
it's early an earlier just hear those
sleigh bells ringing ding ding jingling
- how [ __ ] you our Christmas songs they
don't even write them their sole accent
is it lacks a basic allure lack of days
ago [ __ ] that word its lack of they lack
some days ago jazz hear those sleigh
bells ringing Lin Jing Jing jingling - I
can't even think about it
well let's sort of record another one
really yeah cool yeah let's record
another one even write it nope Oh jingle
bells jingle bells jingle all the way
jingle farken jingle alright we'll put
it on wax
yourself a merry little Christmas
sebacic may your days be brah eat Spacek
its lackadaisical why do people say
laksa days ago I knew it was lack of
days ago I [ __ ] knew was
lackadaisical and somebody years ago
told me was laksa days ago they made me
feel stupid the whole party was like you
[ __ ] idiot it's [ __ ] lackadaisical
goddamn I don't remember who those
people were but [ __ ] you just hear those
sleigh bells ringing ding ding jingling
- such a [ __ ] you just like like you
know just hear those sleigh bells
first of all Ringel in and then jing
jing jingling so shitty i'm so
disrespectful what's the one keep it
what's the song that goes keep his
spirits spirit with you just what's it
keep there was one song song I was
saying earlier together about the
spirits and it was like I wanted to talk
about it later cuz it was so [ __ ] you a
camera what it is every song every
Christmas song has spirit in it silent
night holy night always imagine that
song as like they they're like when
they're singing they're literally like
oh we gotta keep coming up with lyrics I
can't cuz I gotta I'm nasally but mmm
God everybody has their own oh that
everyone has III it just bothers me how
every singer has to come out with their
own rendition of a [ __ ] sing a
Christmas song you know what I mean
laughing through the snow on a one-horse
open sleigh over the fields we go
laughing all the way ha ha ha ha I mean
nothing nah does now how goes do it
taking some many liberties first of all
or hey dude put all and I know I'm the
last person to say this because this
podcast has its own language but put all
the goddamn letters in the [ __ ] song
it's kind of this [ __ ] though you got to
admit over the fields we go laughing all
the way but I like when they do or the
fields we go laughing all the way ha ha
ha that's how it should be I don't like
when they [ __ ] every you'll get like
Harry Connick jr. you know laughing all
the way ha ha ha ha you know what I mean
don't [ __ ] make it your own dude
shell son Bobcats when I hang and I'm
making spirits bright oh I'll put all
the [ __ ] letters or the yields we owe
a thing all the way do it like that do
it like that I'll have so much more
respect for you it King Eretz I ate an
orzo into a or that yields week all that
to me is this [ __ ] didn't make that song
laughing all the way up see dasyam
didn't demand aha if they did that'd be
my favorite Christmas song of all time
don't just use our because that's the
thing that bothers me don't just use the
one or if you're gonna do more
contributed the contractions make the
song that way don't [ __ ] slip in a
contraction like acute all of a sudden
[ __ ] you know Michael Buble some
singer Michael Buble he gets a pass cuz
he basically just sings Christmas songs
all year long no matter what he's
releasing you know
like put on any Michael Buble song
during first message you know you won't
even know that you'd be like I was this
is just a regular Mike couple a song I
mean this is just a Christmas song
anyway how about DMX is Rudolph the Red
Nosed Reindeer song F [ __ ] terrible
just like it was better when he just did
it with his [ __ ] hands and about that
pop hmm
I like when DMX like would sing no you
know no you know that car no the black
albinos coming to like a rhino on crack
set it with a runny nose and glassy eyes
you know that gan oh the black albinos
coming through with like a rhino on
crack
here we go babies it's time to back up
that [ __ ] Brinks truck blue
apron is the number one fresh ingredient
in wrist recipe delivery service in the
country do you know that its mission is
to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone and they'd add
add blue apron achieves this by
supporting a more sustainable food
system highest standards for highest
ingredients and building a community of
home chefs they got the two-person meal
plan serves two people eight new recipes
per week with the choice to receive
either two or three recipes any week
family meal plan meals that serve four
people wine plan six bottles of wine
from renowned wine makers delivered
monthly I mean what what does this cost
four million dollars no cuz it's like so
affordable featured upcoming meals chili
butter steaks with lemon parmesan
broccoli and potatoes YUM gonna stop
this podcast right now go find that
spicy shrimp
bucatini with cabbage and toasted bread
crumbs
bro if you don't even know what the
ingredient bucatini if you don't even
know what it is
imagine how mouth water and it is
roasted chicken with a maple butter come
on dude I don't even know what that is
blue apron is treating congratulations
with Krista leah listeners to their
first three meals of $30 value with your
first order if you visit blue apron com
/ Congrats so check out this week's menu
and get your $30 off with free shipping
a blue apron our calm / Congrats blue
apron a better way to cook maple butter
Square cash it seems that all of my
troops and babies and cult members are
switch into the cash up and it's the
number one flight finance app in the App
Store maybe it's because it's the best
way to pay people back friends family
coworkers
even if you're a kuda use square cash
sending and receiving money is totally
free and fast and most famous can be
deposited directly in your bank account
in seconds you hear that Square cash is
better than the other apps man it's not
a social network who wants to have the
payments listed in the feet I don't want
people knowing that I paid somebody for
trash bags cash card is a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app the cash card allows you to
use the cash that you keep in your app
anywhere you want you'll get
notifications for payments made with the
card directly via the cash out you
laser-etched your card to personalize it
and it'll be delivered directly to you
for free you can draw anything on this
card you draw a CUDA you draw Reggie
Jackson you could do whatever you want a
heart and the cash app team is the cool
thing is constantly building new awesome
features so what are you doing using the
other guys get to cash up today download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
did we're backing up this [ __ ]
Brinks truck mmm nothing god
you know what I keep seeing online is
and not even online just in people
people people gotta stop
you know girls actually girl this is a
girl thing only girls do this you got to
stop talking about how Elon Musk is
husband material okay
not because he's not but because that's
like saying Jesus Christ saved people
okay
oh dude oh really Oh
Elon Musk is husband material to you in
a [ __ ] one-bedroom apartment cooking
[ __ ] steak comes at 4:30
cuz you woke up at 1:00 oh dude hey oh
really
rocket building you on musk genius
world-changing somehow
hair grower that [ __ ] was bald
twelve years ago
he is
Oh silly anair Elon Musk is husband
material
to you and your [ __ ] duplex husband
material you don't deserve to say yo
dude really
Elon Musk is husband material oh really
hey I wonder [ __ ] why that [ __ ] drives
me up a wall you pizza [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
cat owning [ __ ] you know what
I'm talking about
uh that's husband material right there
in the mica in the meantime this guy's
working every day to save the [ __ ]
planet [ __ ] and you're trying
on outfits the [ __ ] go north to the
[ __ ] northeast spot in Canada you
[ __ ] Kudus Oh Elon Musk is husband
material Jesus Christ save people and
[ __ ] Sammy Davis jr. had a glass eye
what the [ __ ] else can I find out on
Wikipedia husband material dude [ __ ] out
of here
why so you could take half well you want
half a rocket were you trying to go
where air is thinner [ __ ] out of here
dude for real show us a watch on
Instagram but secretly show us your
[ __ ] cleavage can't wait to [ __ ]
where my new watch Thanks tits out
[ __ ] Photoshop hips out waist in
can't wait look at the new ring I got by
the way check out MMD's you're trying to
go where the airs thinner [ __ ] off dude
Elon Musk is husband material
you think [ __ ] Elon Musk doesn't know
that [ __ ] is he sink by the way he knows
it so much he's single he's not married
he's he married he's got kids
he's married okay you know what
who gives a [ __ ] if he's married or not
doesn't matter you know why you got the
same amount chance of [ __ ] Elon Musk his
husband here
that really drove me that driving me but
I see all the time just [ __ ] put in
the search bar Elon Musk husband
material on Twitter it'll be like a
[ __ ] groceries it'll be like a
[ __ ] Rite Aid receipt this [ __ ] just
coming out it'll be like the masks
tongue when he sees [ __ ] Cameron Diaz
for the first time but it attack that
talk across the table musk is three
times divorced Wow same girl twice haha
what is it twenty billion dollars net
worth dude that's weird that a twenty
guy with twenty billion dollars you
think is [ __ ] a husband material
uh these [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
I'll getting remarried Andrey divorce
how about getting divorced
and then being like you know how many
times that guy's [ __ ] that guy should
just get never mind tattooed on his
forehead or no around his ring-finger
we want to get married never mind let's
get divorced never mind let's get
married
never mind let's get divorced that guy
[ __ ] it that guy will do whatever he
wants I mean he makes Rockets he's the
[ __ ] but people say that that's the
whole thing man that that [ __ ] herd
mentality that we have man is especially
online it's just like somebody says
something and then all of a sudden
that's what it was with pizza somebody
[ __ ] said uh pizzas the best some
[ __ ] skinny model said oh I love
pizza
and then all the girls jumped on a
bandwagon was like how great is pizza I
eat it all the time
because
they wanted to seem like a [ __ ]
normal person when you know they're
throwing it the [ __ ] up oh yeah you're
eating pizza like [ __ ] biles not
shooting out of your goddamn face thirty
minutes later and then and then and then
it got so [ __ ] rampant that these
[ __ ] beta [ __ ] dudes are like
I love my pizza go [ __ ] out of here man
get the [ __ ] out of here
beta do it your own thing man how much
do I like pizza and then let me tell you
something pizza is [ __ ] so good dude
but it's not cute to talk about it
online anymore Oh
Elon Musk is husband material go [ __ ]
eat pizza man
go [ __ ] eat pizza go go eat pizza we
go eat half of Elon Musk's pizza and the
same girl that'd be like Elon Musk is
husband material will be the same
[ __ ] girl seven years into the
marriage just like all he does is work
on his Rockets all he does is work in
his Rockets he ignores me I want romance
you know and then they'd [ __ ] some guy
with a long coat
[ __ ] man mmm what's happening I don't
know yeah that's that's the one um
[ __ ] man I'm on I'm on [ __ ] I'm on
I'm on one tonight today or whatever you
know the lack of days ago but [ __ ]
that's what's up I don't know I don't
really have anything else I could keep
going no I guess when I first started
this podcast I was like how the [ __ ] am
I gonna talk for an hour
literally I was like how am I gonna do
that and I know I'd do it on stage but
like I know what I'm gonna talk about
but here I don't I just kind of [ __ ] and
talk about what happened in the week
sometimes I jot down words or bullet
points but I feel like after three or
four episodes I was like you know I was
I was I was it just became he easier you
know I guess uh all right so I wanna I
wanna I want to actually announcement
this wasn't even a schedule but I wanted
to know I want to announce a a an elder
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
announce an elder this week and this is
going to go to grace and Parks GRA CEA
and NEPA our KS and this is just gonna
go to her for overall support of the
podcast she constantly tweets about the
podcast I saw it today she was going on
a job a job interview she put it on an
Instagram story or something like that
and tagged me something like that she
was wearing a crystal Leah's shirt for
luck this girl I just like her vibe and
I liked her attitude and she seems like
a real [ __ ] cool person and I want to
make her an elder for constantly
supporting the podcast and constantly
supporting me and I want to invite her
to enjoy to join us at the [ __ ] log
cabin whenever the hell that's happening
and she's just a true member of the cult
and a [ __ ] like this girl man and I
just kind of I you know I don't know her
but online I support the kind of [ __ ]
that she does and I think that she's
great I think she writes for like she
writes articles for somebody I don't
know but uh she's she seems like a cool
chick so congratulate her grace and
Parks and there's our new Elder and
we'll DM you for the for the info and
[Music]
and we'll send you your pinning your
certificate so thanks for the support
and yeah I guess we could do Twitter
Kirk oh I actually I had some good most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the week Man
1 made me laugh real hard it was short
and sweet I hope they didn't delete it
this is it okay here we go hey guys it's
time from the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week
of the week hey dude this one's this one
actually made me laugh out loud hard I
got it from a DM you guys DM me a lot of
most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
week sometimes it's how I get him
there's a business selfie of a girl with
okay it's just as healthy really it
looks as she's driving or something this
is the caption and then I'm gonna tell
you something about the selfie I opened
two gifts this morning they were my eyes
today I am extremely thankful that I can
see what a blessing that is that's the
caption dude imagine a
imagine waking up and thinking that
imagine god here's the thing about that
this is how that went down
she definitely thought about opening her
eyes and how and also opening gifts and
thought that like aw whether she knows
it or not she thought oh it's like
opening eyes and you opened gifts too
huh I that's kind of cute opening eyes
well there you know I'm opening eyes is
kind of a gift so that's probably an
offer I opened my eyes those are the two
bets like that's how she thought of that
which is the backwards way of thinking
that she thought of the cute thing first
and then [ __ ] thought oh I'll put it
on Instagram and and I opened two gifts
this morning and led us down a [ __ ]
path a poetic path s poetry you just
wanted to seem clever okay you didn't
walk around all day thinking about how
lucky and blessed you're to see I mean
unless his girl had I look if this girl
had eye surgery and had a [ __ ] eye
cancer and then [ __ ] now that's why
she's posting it then obviously what I'm
saying goes out the [ __ ] window
because yeah but if you're just reg and
you're just like man I'm wrong it's so
cool I can see you're [ __ ] high I
mean come on dude today I open my today
open to gifts this morning my eyes ah
see ya imagine that's the person you
look up to next and they just [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
opens get my two gifts today eyes and
being like soon and papers [ __ ]
slowly hit the ground like cartoons and
then you arrive to your nested text
destination like like the roadrunner I
opened my two favorite gifts today my
eyes poom brachii in some other [ __ ]
raka I mean dude there's some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] out there we've got to clean some
[ __ ] up like this we got to clean that
[ __ ] up before we feed the [ __ ]
homeless otherwise it's not gonna happen
we gotta clean that [ __ ] up before we
[ __ ] fight these fires man [ __ ] [ __ ]
man
so funny man what the [ __ ] oh okay
alright let's go to Twitter questions I
like this one this one's by I can't
really see the thing can you turn it
bigger MX LZ at max sleaze you know
change it not not the great climate to
be didn't wanted to be known as it is a
sleaze you know you jerk off in a plant
max lease at Crystal yeah there's a guy
at my gym who drinks hot [ __ ] coffee
while he works out I love coffee but egg
to dunk
congratulations pot gaming the system
yeah bro
how about this don't don't bring any
liquids to the gym that can injure
somebody I don't need to get [ __ ] a
third-degree burn while I'm while I'm
doing lat pull-downs that's [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] they should tell him to [ __ ]
take a hike man
I mean take a hike
don't [ __ ] one time my uncle got mad
at my cousin my cousin because my cousin
was like just playfully saying like
after after high school he's like I
don't really want to go to college and
then my uncle goes like this don't go
don't go that like so unwarranted and it
was like so obvious that they had like a
previous conversation about it or
something and like so much pent-up
energy that was like don't go that you
know be a failure don't go it was so
funny man whee laughs whee laughs whee
laughs what are you okay here we go
Knotts later at was almost Slater I mean
[ __ ] how confuse is this guy
cool man hey but what are you I think
this doesn't we almost were and what
you're not but who are ya that's a guy
who lives in Albuquerque by the way who
are you he does no idea who he is he's
for sure in Albuquerque New Mexico dude
Albuquerque New Mexico is so Albuquerque
and no other places like that I know I
said this before but it's so weird with
the Aztec ian's art what do you think
about the new obsession with crypto
currency like Bitcoin here's the thing
about Bitcoin I saw a meme page one of
my one of my the mean pages I like I
can't remember it was sorry I can't
remember but but they were they made a
mean about this thing I think that is
true though actually Bitcoin you could
actually buy physical bitcoins now and
the meme was like and it came full
circle like that's just money you
[ __ ] morons oh you can buy the whole
idea was do it my buddy Keegan Allen was
trying to explain to me about bitcoins
and I literally might as well have just
been like this he was like breaking it
down and being like so it doesn't exist
right but here's the deal and I was like
he just said so I don't know I actually
don't even know how to
mockingly make fun of it is how [ __ ]
dumb I was I was about it he was like so
it's really hard to explain but and I
was like okay I really gotta listen here
we go
and then he started explaining and by
four words in I was just going like this
way right back up a little bit no clue
no clue what I do know is I have a
friend that tells me he invested 200
dollars in it and now has 56 grand and I
know he's wrong I know he's wrong I know
he's wrong because he tells me hey man
it's up to 56 grand now unwarranted and
I'm just like ah cool I text back and I
know he's wrong and I know he believes
it and I know he thinks he has it but I
also know he doesn't have it and I'll
say stuff to him they're like oh well
the interesting thing about that is it's
not true I mean dude you know oh it's a
good one it's Christmas spirit one
making spirits bright and on horse open
sleigh o'er the fields we go laughing
all the way ha ha ha ha when did you
stop believing in Santa Claus spelled it
wrong no II at the end they are [ __ ]
what was the guy who did that potato dan
quayle dude I saw tweet the other day
that was like Dan Quayle not knowing how
to spell potato ended his political
career which is true and it's [ __ ]
hilarious because now you can murder
someone and be the lord of the world
when did you stop Vincent Lecky ardougne
oh hey man are you wearing a wife-beater
cuz you're so Italian you have pasta in
your mouth right now
this is how he must have said this hey
when did you stop believing in Santa
Claus and did you find out or did
someone tell you
I mean s Italian Vincent liquor Donnie
hey he's [ __ ] this is how he [ __ ]
tweeted it
hey past that [ __ ] garlic bread when
did you stop believing in Santa Claus
and did you find out or did someone tell
you hey that sources good bring it home
it's like how my used to make hey hold
on one for good measure not for nothing
but you know we got to make sure that
it's all done get the whole you know
make sure everything's done he's shot
take the sauce the whole nine come on
[ __ ] carmine
let's go carmine get the sauce and [ __ ]
his carmine trying to put a whack on
this [ __ ] come on stick the
[ __ ] sauce when did I stop believing
in Santa Claus I was like the last
[ __ ] dude to stop believing in Santa
Claus for real as a matter of fact
almost like 11 and my mom told me that
there was no Santa Claus and I think my
dad got mad at her because the next year
there were stuff under the tree that my
dad put down [ __ ] it was actually so
cute and he was like hey so you wanted
that right and I said yeah and he said
was that he said did did you it was
something like he guessed I wanted or
something he was like how did how did
Santa know you wanted that and I was
like I don't know I didn't tell anybody
and he was like huh so Santa Claus must
be real huh and I was like yeah I guess
so and he was like wanted me to it was
like so [ __ ] cute because I knew even
as a 12 year old as a 12 year old he
wanted me to still believe in Santa
Claus and then my mom [ __ ] it up you
know and I knew they had a kid who could
tell him without me there I know my dad
said what's your [ __ ] tell him
without me there
why'd you [ __ ] don't you think we
should have talked about this I was like
I was old enough my mom was like he's
[ __ ] old enough he's 11 you know and
if it wasn't for that moment I would
still believe in Santa Claus right now
as a 37 year old my mom ruined my life
no I'm kidding and even if she heard me
say that as a joke she'd still feel bad
cuz mom's you know why cuz mom's mom
sure some [ __ ] mom say oh well I am
always wrong that's why because I'm
always wrong that's why right how much
the bomb say [ __ ] like that oh but you
know it's okay to make fun of mom isn't
it um mm-hmm
all right good we're good to go for some
reason my oh it's probably cuz my cell
phone is next to the thing just [ __ ]
interference cool one fire myself in a
tragic in occurrence of events one fire
myself we're gonna wrap up baby listen
man the merch is stocked the merch is
stocked okay
go on go get your Christmas gifts for
everybody do you know that people are
[ __ ] congratulations podcast
listeners dude do you speak the language
to you friends go get a mr. freakin
shirt go get him a CUDA sure go get him
these [ __ ] shirts
I'm their true babies it's great
Christmas gifts and stocking stuffers
subscribe to the YouTube channel too you
get the video watch the podcast now
babies we take we take in over what city
at a time
download the Chris D'Elia app you get
behind the scene [ __ ] as a matter of
fact after we wrap up right here I'm
gonna shoot a video for my app and
[ __ ] berate one fire a little bit uh
order by the end of the week we can to
guarantee domestic shipping by Christmas
subscribe rate and review the show tweet
me by using the handle at congrats pod
or by using the hashtag congratulations
pod or the unofficial hashtag which we
don't check but seems to be always
popping up gaming the system and that's
from a first elder video episodes go up
on Tuesdays or Wednesdays but this one
will go up a little bit later than that
cuz we could drop it later upcoming
shows San Diego we just added another
one due to overwhelming popular demand
Riverside a New Year's Eve come pop some
bottles with me I won't pop bottles but
you can Winnipeg Calgary Saskatchewan
and Pasadena we got new shows coming up
and we're going to be adding a link for
Tampa Florida I'm coming well that's all
my specials man I'm firing or man on
fire or incorrigible on that Netflix or
watch white white male black calming
white male black comic you can get that
on iTunes or the Comedy Central app I'm
gonna be on the good doctor coming up
I'm gonna be on the good doctor coming
up and then I also have a movie coming
out called
[Music]
life in a year and then I was want to
call it something though
life in pieces but doctor came out
already with Katie Holmes seventeen
years ago and then I'm gonna be on a new
show coming up called alone together
which is very funny and thank you for
listening
you guys are awesome sorry the [ __ ] Nara
babies
[Music]